but only your face called shine and give
my house a vitamins of love all my art
and all my works there's about sadness
Melancholy misery and I mean all the
things can help to humans
he likes creating art about things that
can hurt humans
isn't that a red flag I know that there
is a Madness inside of me
that I showed in my poetry and in my
painting we finally meet Debbie's 24
year old boyfriend Usama and if you
thought she was a character
you ain't seen nothing yet I feel
comfortable with cuts sometimes more
than people because God
they are silence and the contract and
silence and they can feel you in the
right way not like people I
understood him to be kind of like like
Lone Wolf in his community plus I have a
sneak peek of my exclusive chat with
Debbie for you where we talk about
usama's Madness their intimacy and she
reacts to her son's heartbreaking plea
for her to not leave at the airport he's
young mom part of me he's always gonna
beat myself up make sure you subscribe
to et's YouTube channel so you can catch
the full interview when it drops people
compare you to Angela
another 90 day cast member but how do
you feel about those comparisons I have
much more high ideals let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia how
are you how are you feeling I hope
everyone is good and if not remember it
does not rain forever what's on the
other side of what you're growing
through
yes what you're going through is better
trust it I also want to take a moment to
stay salbona to our South African
viewers I just returned from Cape Town
y'all it was my first time in the
motherland and woof the beauty the
people the food the chicken it was
seasoned so well it could be dry and
it's still good
that says a lot also the music I had a
beautiful time I love your country next
time I'm gonna go to joburg Durbin
I want to see it all all right moving on
let's get into arguably the most
interesting couple on the other way
right now Debbie and Usama
before I mean David I didn't look for
any preference just I mean I wanted to
be alone
just sit and try to go sometimes if
there is someone who can understand me
or someone who can love me truly as I am
and so deeply comes to my way after
I know the tippy is very older than me
but I believe that Jesus is a number and
the soul never grow and if there is a
feeling of something between two persons
is between the souls it's not the bodies
[Music]
that's deep Osama literally feels like
he hopped out of one of Debbie's
paintings onto the screen he has such a
distinct character I describes myself as
alone he talks to cats and he loves
silence
God's
head of Silence on the contract and
silence and the gun feel you in the
right way not like people
I like to walk in the farm because you
know reduce you and animals until father
and silencer Osama yes he is a quiet man
but sometimes you know with me just
being a motor mouth sometimes he kind of
looks fascinated and he gets his his
mind going in another Direction he keeps
everything locked up inside and he gave
me the key he said Miss Debbie got the
key to osama's Heart Osama also looks at
pigeons as if they are God's gift to
this planet he feels like someone out of
a movie or a book right
he's interesting because a part of him
seems very pure this girl is like a lion
last month plus she gets saved I mean
God save her but then he has this other
side that
sounds very dark all my art and all my
works there's about sadness Melancholy
misery and I mean all the things can
help humans I know that there is a
Madness inside of me
that I sure was in my poetry and in my
painting
let Debbie's son Julian hear that she is
often mentioned that he has some kind of
Madness and then he even tells me Debbie
you have holy Madness and it's like it
became kind of a catch phrase Laura
forbid but he might have to put those
police officer skills to the ultimate
test and go rescue his mom for real
I can see it now taken a son's quest to
rescue his elderly mother from a mad 24
year old man well how old is he he's 24
years old 12.
now look to be transparent
I'm trying to be mindful about how I
talk about Usama because I don't like
for people who already feel
misunderstood to feel even more
misunderstood everybody has their
interest and I don't know what he's gone
through I just hope he's a type that
sticks to expressing his Madness through
the Arts and not through hurting people
just saying you got to listen to people
when they talk and not take things like
what he said lightly
speaking of that Usama says that he's
not trying to marry Debbie immediately
although she thinks that's what's
happening much before me and dbabid I
need some time to know each other more
in reality
I wonder if he's going to be living in
this apartment that Debbie's getting as
they get to know each other more once
Osama and I get our apartment I'm having
Julian send over the rest of my stuff if
you are unaware Usama who describes
himself as a writer painter poet lives
at home and doesn't have a job his
reason Abdullah can kill the creations
wow he is really living by that
hopefully his Creations can make some
money and he doesn't always have to rely
on Debbie in her pocketbook
Debbie has a pocketbook not a purse I
feel when you love and care about a
person you want them to have good things
in their life so yeah I've sent him
money for groceries uh he's sending
money to Veterinary money for his cat
it's like compassionate things another
fact about Usama is that he's also
Muslim which makes me wonder is he going
to try to get Debbie to convert
could you imagine
[Music]
what DB you have a revelation a full
moon a tree and a rose the Sun get
Julius when you walk beside me but only
your face called shine and give my house
a vitamins of love
well now that we've met the man who has
67 year old Debbie moving across the
world let's get into her goodbye to her
kids
this is the stupidest thing I've ever
heard in my entire life
I think my mom is making a horrible
decision and she's not she's not
thinking like a normal person ask her
son Julian who has been against this
move from the beginning is driving her
to the airport Debbie calls her daughter
Sandy who tries to talk her into staying
Sandy I naturally I'm going to come back
and visit and I'd like for you to come
to Morocco and visit too it's hard
[Music]
but it's like you're gonna make
very strong loyalty gonna do what you
want to do well no we don't want you to
even though we're advising otherwise
well I love you and I appreciate your
care and concern but I think that you
kids should have a little more faith in
me Debbie goes on to reassure Sandy and
Julian that although she's leaving they
are her everything I love you Sandy and
I'll talk to you later bye-bye
see Sandy's civil and nice you know damn
well she's not civil on Earth the way
Debbie and her son speak to each other
would sound disrespectful coming out of
anyone else's mouth but coming from them
it's actually endearing you sure you
want to do this yes
or make you change your mind that's my
new nickname
determine Debbie determine Debbie
they clearly have a strong bond which
understandably has Julian afraid to
death to lose his mom listen to him beg
her to stay at the airport I'm scared
I'm scared you won't get hurt I'm scared
of something bad may happen nothing
bad's gonna happen
I want you to be happy for me I mean
in a different situation I've been super
ecstatic for you but it just to me
doesn't add up right
he's young mom
's like my best friend you know I mean
mom is kind of like the she's the crazy
group of the family
and I know when I have issues or invite
me to blow off steam I could just go to
Mom's house you know or if I just need a
break from everything stay at Mom's
house you know and uh now that's not
gonna happen you know some somebody
stole our mom from us
here's what Debbie had to say about
Julian's heartbreaking plea my son and
my daughter and uh they have loved me so
much they have been my best friends and
my kids I mean it doesn't get any better
than that my relationship with my
children and they turned out fine even
though it's like
I didn't have a lot of good skills
but love covers everything love and
positive reinforcement and encouragement
and yeah you know part of me is always
going to beat myself up it's like hey
Debbie why'd you leave your kids Behind
they love you so much
[Music]
foreign
I really don't want you to go
is there anything I can do or pay you
money to stay no nothing I can do this
My Mind Is Made Up After Julian accepted
that his mom is leaving he gave her a
kiss admitted that he's not good at
goodbyes and walked off without looking
back
know he was hurt
[Music]
now we wait to see Debbie and Usama
together
that should be a treat
with me
and now I need my ass
he looks handsome all right one quick
update before I go so you can stay in
the loop after stressing about johann's
butcher shop that isn't making money
having a baby at 42 and looking for
apartments Danielle is now concerned
about whether she can even trust Johan
no it all started when Danielle's Friend
Sophie asked Johan if he has any other
children and he said he doesn't but then
he shared this about his past
relationships
foreign
women have gotten pregnant but they
haven't been able to
about a person
have avoided the babies on purpose
is it just me or is it concerning that
he's just out here getting women
pregnant like that wow that's the first
time I'm hearing that
Danielle who has dealt with
untrustworthy men in the past was
shocked by this conversation and said
that Johann told her that his Partners
have lost children but never that one
got an abortion he had told me that she
lost the baby and had a miscarriage like
why would you lie about something like
that that doesn't make any sense to me
like why do you not
say that before
I'm not upset about the abortion I'm
upset that Johan hasn't been honest with
me and my full faith in this
relationship is about my faith in him
and his honesty and if I lose that then
what do we have
the episode ends with Danielle calling
Johan toxic you're a toxic human right
you are a toxic human see and she gets
even more upset after she sees that her
husband doesn't even try to console her
or make things better all he keeps
saying is the past is the past
I really want a child and I really
wanted it with him because of who I
believed he was and it's like if that's
not actually who he is then what am I
fighting for they can be a lot to watch
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all I will see you next time
foreign